hello everyone and welcome to the match
that just keeps on giving it's young
sister of duda versus magnus carlsen and
this is game three of their second match
and now magnus won the first match uh
uh without even reaching game four so he
just won two games uh and in the drew
one game and now he needs uh a quiet day
basically to wrap things up and win the
entire thing but the first game ended in
a draw or rather the first game magnus
won and uh pretty much it's it's over he
won the first match he won the first
game in the second match but then duda
retaliates in game two magnus had a
winning position then he blundered into
a drawn position and then he uh just
blundered even further into a lost
position which allowed to do the back
into the match and now this is game
three uh the most thrilling game of the
uh of the of the match so far maybe not
in its longevity but um
uh you know
in its uh was the opposite of longevity
and it's brevity uh so let's dive
straight into it and enjoy as there is
quite a lot to enjoy so here uh duda
opens with e4 we have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and now duda surprises
magnus very early on so there are many
many good options here we've seen uh
some of them quite a lot like bishop c4
bishop b5 we even see the scotch we even
see the three nights the the four nights
game so we see a lot of stuff but ponte
g3 we do not see very often this is the
constantinopolsky variation and uh it is
a very very uh uh rarely played but
magnus has played it himself um uh
against lavon arunian and also yanni
palmishi uh has played this uh
g3 move uh so let's see uh how the game
continues uh we have d5 uh challenging
the the central structure if
white allows it why not
we have captures the queen captures and
now knight to c3 much like you would see
in a scandinavian defense for example
queen back to d6 now bishop to g2 and
the bishop to g4 so the game continues
exactly at the game uh magnus carlsen
versus uh lebon arunyan from the 2019
london chess classic uh h3 bishop to h5
and here
in that game that we mentioned magnus
continued with the g4 but here duda
doesn't uh play the move magnus played
even uh nipple played this against
arunian he played the g4 here but duda
plays d3 and it is now as of move eight
that we have a completely new game so
magnus advances the pawn to f6 he wants
to strengthen his center even though an
argument could be made for a move like
f5 as white is castling kingside and
black will
feel this later on so here magnus plays
f6 we have castles magnus castles queen
side we have castles on opposite sides
of the board so you know you know what
is uh
coming
and duda does not give magnus even a
second to start his expansion on the
king side he of course plays the move
that is always great and that is pawn to
b4
and now when you see this of course if
magnus captures this then magnus will
will pretty much be defending for the
rest of the game you know the bishop
here controls this beautiful diagonal
the rook is coming to b1 it's not going
to be easy and best is probably to just
play f5 and continue pushing if b for
knight d4 and well it's it's a race uh
maybe that's why uh pawn belonged to f5
all along but okay magnus accepts the
challenge he plays queen captures on b4
and now the fight is definitely on the
knight on c3 is hanging do the defense
it and also threaten some very nasty
discoveries so magnus plays queen to a5
interestingly there are no nasty
discoveries here even though it looks
quite unpleasant but now a3
knight g to e7 uh continuing development
as magnus still has a lot of pieces to
develop and rook to e1 uh and here and
not uh wanting his bishop here uh uh to
to just sit as the the knight isn't uh
really important here the bishop defends
it so the queen can move uh magnus plays
bishop to f7 and now there is a problem
yes he gains more control over the d5
square but the bishop here
is undefended and it seems like a silly
thing to say so what if the bishop on f7
is undefended look at all the army
around the bishop
well that's exactly how chess works here
duda plays knight to e4 he opens up a
discovery to cross and queen queen to a4
and now comes knight to c5 again
attacking the queen queen to b5 and here
comes
a moment where the weird positioning of
the bishop on f7 could have been
exploited uh so i'm not gonna show you
what happened uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for duda while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
really really well uh beautiful line uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is knight captures on
e5 interestingly it is not what the duda
played but i will still show it now the
point is this would not have been
possible if the bishop on f7 was
defended but now the bishop on f7 is
undefended we are threatening to capture
it and fork both of the rooks
so what could magnus play here well he
could play f characters on e5 right
there's nothing better but now comes
queen g4 check and after king b8 there's
knight captures on b7 completely
shattering carson's defenses opening up
this diagonal for the light square
bishop and also just rook uh rook to b1
is coming there is no uh no no good move
here for for black you might capture the
knight and then comes rookie to b1 black
will have to give up the queen of course
black did get some material for the
queen so it would be very interesting
but should be
should be enough for white to win the
game so after queen to b5 dude doesn't
find this he plays bishop to b4 uh or he
he
solidifies the position now he will have
some ideas like c4 and now magnus
quickly plays uh a knight captures on b4
knight the
f5 was also interesting uh but this is a
rapid game you do not have all the time
in the world so knight captures on b4 a
captures on b4 and now knight to c6
adding something in between this bishop
and this pawn because you know that if
this opens up it's not going to end well
and now duda does not play knight
captures an e5 like in the variation
that we've shown but rather knight to g5
and again uh how silly is this bishop on
f7 but white doesn't even care about the
bishop now white just wants this uh
queen to g for check so here if captures
on g5 there's really nothing better
otherwise you're just going to lose a
whole lot of material queen to g4 with
check kink to b8 and now knight to d7
here you don't have knight captures here
but you have knights to d7 check and now
the rook has to be captured you can't go
here because then of course you just go
under the mask of the queen and if you
go king to a8 we just push c4 beautiful
stuff queen captures on b4 and now
bishop captures on c6 b captures rook e
to b1 and you are not surviving this
position for example queen to d6 we're
gonna play queen to d1 and now uh
there's no defending queen a four queen
captures an a7 checkmate it's just game
over so uh that would happen if uh
magnus moved the king so magnus gives up
the rook here queen captures on d7 and
now we have bishop captures on b4
you might think but why bishop captures
on b4 if the bishop on f7 is hanging
well this bishop is so silly uh in this
game that you can't even save it even
when it's directly attacked if you move
it let's say bishop to g6 we can just
capture on c6 and once b captures and c6
is played queen to d8 check king to b7
and now rook captures on a7 so black's
defenses get shattered regardless of
what magnus plays king captures rook to
a1 with check and now you're getting
checkmated either remove the king and
you get checkmated via queen to a8 or b8
or you block with the queen but still
just queen captures on c7 with check
king has to move now and now rook
captures will be checkmate so magnus
cannot afford a move to to save this
bishop he plays bishop captures on b4
first and now duda not rushing with some
captures rook e to b1 because his rook
on e1 is hanging as well so rook eat the
b1
and then now comes pawn to a5 uh
guarding this bishop here even though
that's uh not going to work the only way
for magnus to continue fighting was
knight to d4 offering a queen trade and
once aguda finally captures this bishop
we're gonna play queen to c5 this is how
we get away from the b file and we keep
an eye on that c3 square so pawn to c3
does not happen and let's say queen
captures on g7 the rook will come to f8
the game continues magnus will also have
some pressure and it's uh it's a really
a a wild game uh but instead magnus
played a5 uh he uh uh miscalculated uh
his his position and now duda just goes
in for the kill bishop captures on c6
what do you play if you play queen
captures on c6 then we're just gonna
trade captures captures rook captures on
a5 you're gonna lose the bishop as well
and that's it let's say rook to e8 we're
gonna play rook captures on b4 with
check and whatever you play we're gonna
even trade off the rooks here captures
captures king capture 78 and that's it
of course the end game would be
completely winning for duda so after b
bishop captures on c6 we have queen to
b6 by magnus keeping
himself into the game but now c3 now
this bishop cannot move as uh the queen
would hang while this bishop is still
hanging so magnus finally brings the
rook into the game defends the bishop
on f7 but now c captures on b4 uh we
have a4 and not allowing the position to
open up any further but here duda just
plays queen to e7 attacks the rook and
if the rook moves also the bishop and he
was in this position on move 26 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
26 moves against magnus cross and that
is definitely considered a miniature
this was brilliant stuff by duda and he
completely outplayed him with this weird
opening uh so you know it might might
definitely pick up in popularity at
least in maybe online blitz play but uh
you you see there's a lot of poison to
it uh so here you resign because well
let's say once you play queen captures
on c6 we're gonna play a queen captures
on f8 because you are not giving up this
bishop you were protecting it for so
long you you're not going to give it up
queen to e8 now we just trade captures
captures and you keep the bishop
but white has two rooks so that doesn't
really help you so after queen d7 magnus
of course resigned and the duda really
bounces back in the match he is now
leading the second match and now he only
needs a draw uh to take things into tie
breaks we'll see what happens will
magnus maybe win the fourth one and
close it all or we'll do that for sky
breaks and then
well uh who knows what will happen we
will definitely continue uh checking it
out so yeah that's the game hope you
enjoyed it really really impressive
stuff against the world champion magnus
crossing uh i would like to thank
blueberry friends twitter rob rob
antonio's sharp fade the david jarnot
and you not to me for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here uh thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible event
until it ends so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend